foreign
the three Muslims today we are back with
the home base and the man himself the
giant man himself the Warner how you
guys doing today
I appreciate you guys having me on the
stream and alhamdulillah I am doing
absolutely fantastic
together
doing good doing good well how about I
see you got the plaque in the back man
what uh what sub count was that for
um you already know a million Subs now
no no this is the this is the 100K
bro the million Subs is gold not silver
I don't
know
about it all right welcome everybody to
the stream uh
and um all right so brother you just got
back from a place which I don't know if
I can disclose or not but you might have
put the very particular individual as
well are you okay to talk about this
stuff
yeah yeah let's talk about it all right
all right
Gotta Be You can't be too careful these
days man so you just got back from Dubai
and you met up with the shooter you have
multiple Parts out on um kind of a life
A Day in the Life for shooter is that
right yes absolutely yeah all right all
right so what was that like you just
kind of pulled up and you filmed the
whole day with him man that must have
been exciting yeah yeah alhamdulillah
was really nice
um I initially met a satorial shooter
through you guys alhamdulillah and then
um you know we stayed in touch and he
said he wanted to film some content so
alhamdulillah you know I was booking a
trip to the holy city of Mecca uh for
Ramadan and I decided to just do a
little pit stop in Dubai you know for
about four or five days
um and alhamdulillah you know in the
process of me stopping by there I
decided uh you know to meet up with him
alhamdulillah we filmed for the whole
day and it was an amazing little series
it's actually still to be continued
there's actually a lot more that we had
to discuss and talk about well obviously
we're only limited uh in the hours that
we have in the day so alhamdulillah we
had a few different discussions
um on a variety of different topics uh
it is definitely something new for me I
haven't ever created content content
like that before uh but I actually
enjoyed it I quite enjoyed it
was great I think my favorite part was I
think it was part four uh you guys were
I think outside or something like that
am I right
yeah yeah bro that I think that
discussion was Elite I was watching it
while playing chess uh you know of
course alhamdulillah and um bro honestly
everyone check it out inshallah part one
through how many parts are out so
there's only part uh so the first one is
the house tour the second one is Tate
talk uh the third one is talking about
wealth and then the origin story of
satorial shooter
um and then we're gonna have part four
uh and part five which is gonna be
masculinity and then his journey to
Islam as well
saving the last two for the sorry the
last the best two foreign
together which is a bit of a shock so
what's going on with you guys
hey man I'm the love we're just happy to
be here
man's like I'm happy to get in bro
I almost thought that was Photoshop for
a second I was like
I was like
it's a hologram bro he's not actually
here it's a hologram I knew it I knew it
no you guys you guys are awfully silent
today man I'm just Starstruck I want I
want y'all to be like on edge so I could
have the power in this conversation
I did have a question for you so I
wanted to know and I'm sure a lot of the
viewers are wondering this that when you
meet someone in person sometimes it's
different than what you expect you know
virtually or just on the phone so how
was your perception of brother Jewel
different than when we actually met him
in person
so um obviously the Persona I
actually I believe he's a pretty
mysterious figure you know obviously you
see him behind the scenes and stuff like
that uh but nobody really heard much
from him himself uh except through
alhamdulillah you guys had an extremely
viral podcast which Allah Mubarak
congratulations to you guys over 2
million views so shout out to you guys
watch Ella you did a fantastic job you
know um alhamdulillah like kind of
showing a different side of him to the
public so obviously you know when I met
him through you guys alhamdulillah like
I saw a very different side of him
obviously I didn't know much about him
at all I just saw him in the background
in the videos uh you know with Andrew
Tate and so on so forth but
alhamdulillah the brother is an honestly
amazing amazing brother he's very
genuine he's very
um down to earth
um and he's he's honestly like a great
guy martial he's honestly a great guy
and it was a great pleasure and a great
honor uh to meet him and uh to spend so
much time with him as well alhamdulillah
yeah we had a very similar experience
too it's almost like you know they're
low-key everyone usually knows about
them through being in the background or
behind the scenes with Tate and you know
just in the podcast too getting to know
him as a person as a brother in Islam so
much more on you know layering back the
the onion peel you know than what we
thought it would be absolutely
absolutely and you know uh usually when
you meet people in real life their
online Persona is typically a lot better
than what you meet in real life right
but alhamdulillah with him it was
actually I enjoyed his Persona in real
life then you know the the online
Persona as well you know just like you
know usually when you meet people that
are like you know I guess famous figures
or popular figures and then you meet
them sometimes you end up being
disappointed I think there's a saying
that never meet uh you know something
like that never meet somebody that
you've been looking up to your whole
life because most likely you'll end up
being disappointed when you meet them
you know but alhamdulillah with him it
wasn't the case I actually really
enjoyed spending time with him and I
feel like the brother has a lot to say
and a lot to share with the world as
well so I'm excited he also started his
YouTube channel as well which I'm very
excited for and uh yeah man uh more uh
success to him and may Allah you know
continue to give him knowledge and more
power to do uh what needs to be done
inshallah
I mean
what a wonderful Dua and I think it
makes us more excited now to meet other
people in the circle like Tristan and
Andrew Tate and Charlotte in the future
it's almost like Allah is kind of
setting everything up so that we can get
into you know knowing all of them in
depth and just seeing the stark contrast
behind or between what the media will
portray them as versus how they actually
are in person bro because sartorial
shooter Tate you already know how the
media the Matrix is trying to portray
them to be but when we actually got to
know them in person it's so different
bro it's so different and it's a shame
that a lot of people especially those
that are falling for like propaganda
they won't actually get to know them for
who they really are yeah bro it's crazy
that you say that man because they used
to be this guy I used to watch on
YouTube his name was Elliot host have
you ever heard of this guy I heard about
that guy yeah yeah man I had this like
certain perception of him because I used
to watch him way back in the day and
then when we finally met him on a
podcast
it was just very like it was
disappointing to say the least you know
Melody Miller blessing but it was very
disappointing to say at least it wasn't
up to my perception which is crazy that
you said that and uh it leads me to the
questions like did you expect shooter to
be like this because you know we only
spoke with him so much when we were
there we were with him for less than
less than eight hours you know
so that's my question bro did you expect
that did you expect him to be the way
that he is offset
so well the thing is you know obviously
I met him through you guys right you
guys knew more about him and so on so
forth I didn't even know about his
Instagram you know uh page or anything
like that so I was completely blind
going in there you know I mean I just
came in as you guys bodyguard you
already know you know what I'm saying
you don't say so I hope a lot you know
um so yeah I was completely blind going
in but alhamdulillah just you know
spending time with the brother I have a
very good
um idea of how to read people
um as you guys know I've been a
bodyguard for many years for the most
elite um A-list celebrities you know in
uh in the area so alhamdulillah you know
I have a really good perception uh when
I come when it comes to meeting people
and uh kind of uh you know kind of
deciding you know if they're good or bad
vibes you know I'm the line you know
throughout my meeting with him he was
all good vibes Man All Good Vibes so it
was a great pleasure it was a great
pleasure
I like I like the Halal sneaker setup
program yeah bro my camera just is
forcing me into this but it looks pretty
cool and also on hell
oh yeah it looks good yeah I like it
it's a proof it's waterproof you need to
get a step bro you need to get a step
yeah but um yeah I heard you know bits
uh here and there about what you're
saying and yeah
honestly I um I had the same experience
it's weird it's like there's a Hadith
where he mentioned you know I'm gonna
paraphrase a bit but when you meet
somebody and you you know you really get
along with them well you don't know why
um he said that in the world of the
souls
you know it was like you're you're close
to that person
yeah
and the world of the soul is you know
you could have been close to that person
and same if you don't get along with
someone you could have been you know
kind of
yeah you know you could have disliked
that person had beef with them in that
world instead and I'm not saying you
know any of us knew each other
beforehand but when we got there but
you're not saying we didn't yeah but I'm
not saying we did it but when we got
there
he was such a hospital guy a hospitable
guy
you know we pulled up and just from the
second we walked up he was so welcome
welcoming and I think that's a part of
him or a part of you know the the tape
Brothers in that whole group that people
don't really see
and I think that's that's something that
people only see when they actually go
and they hang out with them like that
person from uh Vice Matt or whatever his
name was apparently he had a really good
time and then all of a sudden he comes
out with the hippies against them you
know uh there's another guy I think his
name is something Tilbury Mike Tilbury
something like that he's a tick tock Guy
and um I think he was kind of not beef
with NJ but going back and forth in a
little bit with him and then he met with
him on a podcast and you know it came
out he was very positive afterwards
towards Andrew Tate so I think they're
polarizing figures online yeah people
don't like them but they're actually
really genuinely nice guys
I personally believe there's a lot of
jealousy usually people who live the
high life usually people who are living
you know very abundantly very
extravagant luxurious Lifestyles there
tends to be a lot of hate from all the
broke boys you know what I mean so I'm
not I'm not like I'm not surprised like
me being around the elite of the elite
for many years Mo they had so many
jealous haters around them so this is
something very common if any one of you
guys ever you know want to be successful
one day you have to realize there's
going to be people who are going to hate
on you there's going to be people who
are jealous of you the Quran has warned
us of the jealousy of the envir when
they envy and this is a form of evil so
for me I think it's amazing I think it's
amazing that you can kind of filter out
all the evil haters by just showing a
little sneak peek of your lifestyle so
you know which people not to bring close
to you right away because obviously
nobody wants jealous people around them
you know nobody wants people around them
who want what you have and want it for
themselves instead of you having it and
also you know talking about the brothers
um it was very interesting because when
we went into their house they were
extremely hospitable you know obviously
this is something these are like
mannerisms that typically Muslims have
uh Muslims are extremely hospitable
people if you ever visit a muslim's home
right
um then obviously you're going to be
greeted very well uh for us it's an
extreme honor to have a guest within the
home right there's a saying that if you
haven't had a guests in a while that's
actually not a good thing so when you do
have a guest entering into your home
it's a very pleasant uh and it's a very
blessed experience and you know spending
time with uh you know with uh brother
Jewel you know you could see that
Hospitality
um aspect you know which you know I
haven't necessarily experienced from
many non-muslims but alhamdulillah
obviously the brother is Muslim he
reverted a couple months ago but
obviously as a fresh Muslim I didn't
expect
him to be so hospitable but he was such
a gentleman he was so hospitable like
alhamdulillah like Allah Mubarak you
know
listen he took us into his own home like
family I think the two or three things
we've eaten that day it was always red
meat and vegetables you know and just it
was just a Vibe bro just off camera and
on camera you know but speaking about
the brokies you're talking about what
advice would you have islamically
speaking on people to get their money up
because I think a lot of people have
Envy Envy being something where it's not
only do you just not like something for
someone else but you feel like you
deserve that better and one of the the
antidotes to Envy is just getting your
money up especially when it has to do
with hating on other people for being
higher than you are so what would you
say to position yourself higher
financially to the brothers and sisters
that are watching that are struggling
with that
so I might say something some things
that might be a little offensive and if
it is offensive then yes it's talking
about you all right if you're offended
then obviously you know it's talking
about you okay so if you're broke
especially in the the time that we live
nowadays it's just mainly because you
are lazy you are lazy and you're not
willing to put in the work and when
someone else puts in the work someone is
more smarter than you that does what
you're not doing then obviously they're
gonna get results that you do not get
right but islamically speaking right
it's very important right um for me I
learned this I believe my mother is the
one who shared this with me right she
said that if you want to
um if you never want to be broke right
it's important to read Surah wakia every
single night which is chapter 56 of the
Glorious Quran all right so any of you
guys who are suffering with poverty
um or yeah you guys are suffering with
poverty or you guys are suffering with a
lack of income and stuff like that the
reality is you guys have to read Surah
walking out every single night if I'm
not mistaken there's a promise from
Allah that whosoever reads her walking
out every single night whoever reads
chapter 56 every single night that their
pockets will never be empty and I've
been doing this I think for the past 10
years now and alhamdulillah like it
works every single time it works every
single time and
another thing is you must be grateful
for what you have if you're not grateful
for what you currently have then you do
not deserve any more than what you have
because Allah gives you more you will
still be ungrateful it is important to
be grateful for what you currently have
and then Allah will give you more and
Allah will give you more and Allah will
give you more but you must be grateful
for whatever you have because every
single person has a blessing that
someone else does not have so the first
thing is you must be grateful you must
say alhamdulillah you must
um you know reach Slovakia every single
night before you go to sleep right and
you must work hard and not just work
hard because the brokest people are the
ones who work the hardest so it's a
combination of working hard and working
smart Allah gave you a brain for a
reason so it's important for you to use
it
I have a question bro
I feel like this is something myself and
I think everyone kind of struggles with
how do we remain grateful on a
day-to-day basis not this like fake
gratitude thing where you're telling
yourself oh I'm grateful for this I know
I'm talking about that real gratitude
where it's like damn I'm really grateful
you know like I I went through something
several months back which I'm not gonna
say because I don't want to reveal what
it was but it was very very difficult
and those closest to me definitely no uh
Habibi or hobby bro you know you know
this I told you when we were in uh Saudi
and if you can remember but don't bring
it up don't bring it up don't bring it
up though
hey man
but bro like when I look back to that
that was like I was so grateful for
everything to get out and be able to
experience life and just not be in that
situation so it's like I still try I
still struggle every day where I'm like
man like I'm losing that gratitude and
I'm sure other people as well lose his
gratitude so the question for you Habibi
how do you keep the Gratitude so it's
important to spend time with people who
are less fortunate than you when you are
spending time with people less fortunate
than you immediately you will have an
aspect of gratitude and you know it's
important to do that you're it's
important to spend time with you know
with the poor with the needy and then
you'll see how your life is compared to
their life right and immediately it's
going to leave you in a state of
gratitude so anybody that's wealthy it's
important for wealthy people to spend
time with those who are not as wealthy
so that you may appreciate what Allah
has blessed you with
yeah bro that's that reminds me of
Hadith of the process I'll mentioned
that if you've got to compare yourself
to anyone compare yourself to those that
are beneath you wait wait
I get this and I get this delete as well
I'm very well aware of this but now what
about this whole thing where it's like
the people who you keep around you are
very important so it's like if you keep
people that are at a lower State around
you then you will essentially be holding
yourself at this level of State
so I'm not saying become best friends
you know with the homeless people you
know I'm not saying that you don't say
I'm saying spend time
to spend some time with them so that you
may
um you know you could spend some time
you know in their shoes and therefore
you have you some type of understanding
you know of what they're going through
and you want to do your best to help
them because obviously uh Allah is gonna
especially if you're a more wealthy
individual Allah is going to question
you what did you do on your wealth I
believe there's a saying um that there's
four things that you're going to be
questioned on the day of judgment and
your feet will not move until these four
things are um are answered right and
well first and foremost I think the
first question that's going to be asked
is if you are wealthy what did you do
with your wealth right
um another one is what did you do with
your youth right uh what did you do with
your knowledge and how did you spend
your life right and then no one's feet
on Judgment Day will move move until
these questions are answered so you have
to understand wealth is not just a
blessing it's mainly a test from Allah
right it's a test from Allah so those
who are you know uh you know sometimes
uh someone's wealth will be their
biggest demise especially if they are
stingy they're greedy
um and they're all about just helping
themselves and not helping others then
100 that wealth that same wealth that
they enjoyed is going to be a source of
them being punished in the Hereafter
um
yeah bro and if not in the Hereafter
definitely you know losing wealth in
this Dunya is a test from Allah as well
you know and those that are ungrateful
there's no guarantee you're going to
keep your worth too
absolutely you must not be attached to
these things there's many times where
dude I I lost a lot of money like like
this so but it's all good like for me
alhamdulillah I have no attachment to
these things so
um I'm very grateful I'm very grateful
to Allah Allah is the greatest
absolutely absolutely uh to touch on the
point that or the question Angel asked
you know how do you remain grateful
he made a beautiful comparison uh
between gratitude and patience and he
said they're basically the same thing
and I remember a long time ago I spoke
about this so hopefully inshall I can
remember about he said that gratitude is
patience and good times and patience is
gratitude during hard times
just think about that for a second
you're living a difficult life
and when things are difficult you're
told to not just stay not just to stay
patient right but to stay grateful and
when you're grateful for the little bit
that you have that's what allows you to
remain patient in that difficult time
what people when people lose their
patience is is the moment they think I
deserve more than this I'm poor I
deserve to be rich that's when they have
no patience because they have no
gratitude
all right
but what about when they have more when
they have more they have to be patient
knowing that this might be the peak of
their life right here and it might not
get any better than this and that the
only thing that would be better is
gender
that makes sense because uh there's uh
the one Hadith about the the sun no no
not the Sun but the Adam Adam that Islam
he could be given a valley of gold and
he would just want another value of gold
he will not be content with this value
yeah yeah 100 and that Hadith is it says
the son of Adam meaning all of mankind
so yeah yeah yeah
you know there's another thing too that
the son of Adam right the Sons and
Daughters of Adam will never never be
satisfied right until the dirt is in
their mouth meaning that human beings
were never meant to be satisfied with
this world we were only created to be
satisfied with the afterlife so that's
why when we are in this world and
obviously we live in the western society
and most of the western Society tells us
to chase happiness but true happiness
does not exist in this world it does not
exist in this world we were not created
to enjoy this world because we were
created for the abundance in the
afterlife obviously if you guys have
heard anything about Jannah Jannah
begins where your imagination ends right
so basically
um you know like if you eat from one of
the fruits of Jannah the first bite
right when you take the first bite from
the fruits of Jannah the second bite is
better than the first the third bite is
better than the second and so on and so
forth and Jannah everything gets better
and better and better in this life
everything depreciates you get a brand
new Rolls Royce guess what the next year
is not brand new anymore you get brand
new Mercedes off the lot it depreciates
immediately you get a brand new iPhone
the next one comes out so this world is
nothing but depreciation we we grow
we're one day we're young the next day
we're old you know what I mean this is
just this is how the worldly life is but
the afterlife is completely different
and as Muslims this is what we yearn for
is for the true life the afterlife and
we have an understanding of that that's
why the Muslims are known as the
happiest people in this world right
because we have a certain understanding
of life that other people do not have
and it's all through the guidance of the
Quran it's also the guidance of the
Sunnah of the Prophet Muhammad
yeah that's that's beautifully said and
just to to kind of put the cherry on top
of that people might might feel like
okay so I could just never be happy in
this in this world right there's no true
happiness in this world but there
actually is a form of Happiness even
even the type of happiness that you
might feel in Jannah you could feel in
this world anyone want to guess what
that is
a righteous wife no no no no
that's the best
[Laughter]
it's the best Pastime bro but I know
what you're talking about it's um
uh the moment when a Believer is fasting
and he takes that first bite of the day
he breaks his first or maybe there's a
Hadith about that I wasn't talking about
that I was talking about remembrance of
Allah
oh literally just the remembrance of
Allah because I mean think about it
whenever a person I've experienced this
many times when I remember Allah and I
don't just be like I remember oh yeah
God exists I mean like I really remember
Allah I I Ponder on you know the the
greatness of Allah there's this there's
this feeling that like I could be
completely broke and dying and sick and
like I wouldn't care that's genuinely
how I feel in that moment and there are
two sahaba
where I I've met I've narrated this many
many times but to sahaba they're sitting
basically like at an ocean or something
like that and all they had was dried
bread to eat right all they had was
dried bread and they would dip the dried
bread in the water just to make it
edible because it was so hard it was
difficult to eat so they'd make it wet
in the ocean and then eat it and they
said
if the the the kings of Rome and Persia
knew the happiness for that we had in
our hearts from the Iman that we had
they would send armies to come and steal
it from us
they would send Army to come steal what
they have and these people were dipping
bread in the ocean because they couldn't
even eat it subhanallah
you know there's another thing you know
just to piggyback of what you said that
how can you be happy if the one that
created you is not happy with you right
so just talking about happiness and
stuff like that that a person will never
be able to achieve happiness unless the
one that created them out of nothing is
pleased with them right so obviously if
you're suffering with unhappiness with
depression right mostly most likely it
comes from a lack of gratitude you are
ungrateful and obviously Allah talks
about the people in the Quran mentioning
those who are ungrateful right he
mentions it multiple times The
Ungrateful ones right and indeed human
beings are ungrateful right so it's very
important for us to not be of The
Ungrateful ones if you do want to chase
someone called so on uh you know
so-called happiness you must first
increase your gratefulness you must
appreciate what you have and also
increase your connection with your
creator once you have a better
connection with your creator instantly
you will have a sense of Peace in Your
Heart Right that most people that are
the richest individual in the world they
don't even have that sense of peace and
they're willing to give you all their
wealth into to have that sense of peace
that you have uh you have accomplished
through getting closer to Allah
that's beautifully said bro that's
beautifully said and I think actually
this is how we need to portray Islam to
the people I think this is actually how
we need to give dawa you look at the
sahaba and how they gave dawa it wasn't
in complex ways you know yeah they
didn't have to deal with like complex
arguments either but
Annie they weren't going around trying
to prove God's existence that people
already believed in God right they
weren't going around trying to you know
heavily debate these intricate topics
and all this stuff like you saw how
and I'm gonna pull up a few super shots
in a second inshallah but you saw how
um uh Jafar even Allah he was sent to I
think um najashi who I think was the
king of abyssinia and najashi is a term
by the way it's like it's a title it's
like saying King so there are multiple
najashis over time but this specific one
he went to him and najash is like okay
tell me about your religion he didn't
you know he didn't summarize in the way
people would summarize today oh we're a
Muslim we pray five times a day and we
fasten he didn't say that and I could
pull up the quote for anyone more
specifics but you could find the Hadith
he mentioned things like you know
obviously we worship one God Alone we
abandon idol worship we stop taking a
basically uh uh advantage of the poor we
started treating them well we stopped
things like eating dead animal flesh we
stopped mistreating the people we
stopped you know uh uh doing you know
how do I say it without getting the
stream taken down you know offing our
young daughters and stuff he named all
these practical things that saved
Society
that Islam came and it fixed it helped
you know it made us better people it
fixed our mannerisms
and it's like that is what you know got
him to allow the Muslims to stay with
them I don't I don't I think he accepted
Islam later that najashi but this is
what brings people to Islam they need
things that actually you know resonate
with them in their their human side and
will fix their life you know people have
pain points in life and Islam is is the
cure for us so telling people just to be
grateful for what God has given them and
I'm gonna give a little bit of a
personal uh situation here and you know
giving personal touch points telling
people to be grateful really really
really solidifies in a person's heart
um I hope my sisters don't mind me
telling them this but you know I went to
my sisters
and I really wanted to get them to pray
you know I've been trying for a long
time I really wanted to get them to pray
and I just couldn't so one day I was
just really upset and I go to them and
like they're both just you know laying
on their bed chilling you know doing
whatever they're doing watching a show
or whatever and I walk and I'm like
look at you guys look Allah has blessed
you with such a loving family
an amazing older brother obviously Allah
has blessed you with a family where
you're comfortable you're living in a
safe country you know you have access to
all these safe things you have water at
your disposal you have food you have
healthy bodies you're not you have not
been tested with horrible loss of money
horrible loss of life horrible loss of
Health
and Allah is just all he wants is that
you pray that's all he asks he's like
I'll give you all this for free your
eyesight free ears free every single
thing for free all I want you to do is
to get up and to pray for a few minutes
every single day
that's all you have to do 25 30 minutes
max a day
what would you do for your eyesight if
someone came and said I'm going to poke
out both your eyes you know you have to
give me XYZ I guarantee whatever he asks
you would give him
and Allah gave you your sight for free I
told him that and they're like
okay and then I got him and they started
praying
and by the way Allah I mean Allah I mean
by the way the main point is that they
kept it up afterwards as well they kept
it up and they've only progressed may
Allah
that's the thing with with coming closer
to Allah bro the more you do acts of
worship the more black does that you
remove from your heart the easier it
gets it's supposed to be hard bro in
this transitory period in the beginning
yeah yeah 100 100 alhamdulillah now um
so you know actually I just want to
piggyback off the story that you said
about the king
so you mentioned like
a response it's just a very genuine
response like he he asked him a question
and he gave him a direct answer and I
believe that's what's missing nowadays
it's just a lack of genuinity right just
being humans and talking to each other
like human beings and truly wanting the
best for your fellow human being when
you truly want the best for your fellow
human being and you're a genuine person
and you talk in a genuine Manner and you
talk directly and concisely to them so
they understand it does something to
someone's heart it's words that
penetrate directly into the heart of
another individual and those are to me
are extremely powerful words like
subhana like imagine he's uh talking to
such a uh uh you know uh very uh you
know obviously uh well uh you know
extremely rich king or obviously King
Kings have vast amounts of wealth and so
on and so forth he gave him such a
beautiful genuine answer not carrying
that hey it it may you know it may be
against what he believed but he just
gave him the honest truth and something
about the truth right they say that the
truth hurts right but once you accept
the truth the truth heals
absolutely absolutely 100 and
um
you know
you you see a lot of dawa videos
nowadays and I'm not talking about
anyone's particular because you do need
the intellectual side obviously you do
need like the arguments of that stuff
but there has been such a lack of this
most people don't need like insane
intellectual arguments and stuff right
people most people don't need these deep
deep intricate intricate arguments and
detail-oriented things and
they all they just need is a actual
proper human connection that's all they
really need you know make a fair point a
decent point to connect with them and um
tell them what's up islamically and
it'll resonate in their heart inshallah
but I feel like there's like you've
mentioned there's a huge block of that
nowadays everyone's just focused on like
proving the point and they neglect that
every person is their own individual you
know being they have their own
experiences they have their own needs
their own desires their own wants uh you
know their own pain points that they
need addressed and and they have a right
to know how Islam fixes those problems
in their life you know let's say you
have a woman who is with I don't want to
use the word but a not so great husband
who is not nice to her
um emotionally mentally physically
whatever otherwise and you know she's
really hurt by this and she feels like
maybe she has no way out
you know she should know that in Islam
Islam gives her away oh very easily and
it would reprimand that person as well
and still have that person take care of
his kids as well you know let's say vice
versa you have a man who's really head
over heels for a woman really loves her
but she's completely abusive and not a
physical way because women don't tend to
do that but more manipulative more
emotional more like you know uh you
didn't take the garbage out okay you're
not going to touch me for a week kind of
you know manipulation Islam doesn't
allow that either
either and these are I don't know why
you guys are laughing you know what but
yeah it's something else
you know but these are things that
people experience on a day-to-day basis
and they need they have a right to know
how Islam fixes those problems in their
life
we're not laughing at that bro we're
just like we're cringing at the thought
of that bro
oh yeah I mean that happened
[Laughter]
uh hey but talking about that talking
about that right
um you know uh you know the reason for
me uh what I see when people are doing
these things they're not having a
genuine approach to sharing the message
of Islam is the problem is they're too
busy showing how smart they are right
and the problem is as soon as you start
calling people to yourself instead of
calling people to Islam then you
yourself are the problem so it is uh
this is a problem within the community
but you know may Allah bless them may
Allah you know guide them and may Allah
open their hearts you know to finding
you know the best way of how to give The
Message of Islam and not just trying to
outsmart another individual and to show
that hey I'm smarter than you I can't I
could articulate myself in a certain
manner that you can right that's more
about boasting about yourself more than
it is sharing the message of Islam right
and obviously as soon as you start
calling to yourself and stop calling
towards the message then you yourself
are the problem
100 that's very very Ruth he said and um
I'm glad you mentioned that because like
if a person
is worried about you know how they look
in the eyes of the people uh someone as
a die as a Muslim they shouldn't worry
at all because there's a Hadith that
says
that um
I I'm gonna paraphrase but I believe it
says something along along the lines of
if a person works for the pleasure of
Allah then Allah would put
um the the love of him in the hearts of
the people you know so if Allah loves
you and you're working for the sake of
Allah to please Allah then Allah would
put your the love of you in the hearts
of the people anyways
so if you and it really makes me think
like I think the most noble thing a
person could do is not try and uplift
himself but uplift what is good which is
the truth have you ever seen a person
who only spoke the truth who only
uplifted Islam who only prays Allah and
you thought this person is not a noble
person
no but how many times do we see someone
who you know exactly who was uh the
person that one or mentioned the type of
person who they want to sound cool they
want to sound smart they want to look
good in front of people so they just try
and sound articulate as possible and
they try and sound smart and blah blah
blah
sometimes yeah people will fall for it
other times people be like yeah this
guy's a little bit of a showman you know
doesn't feel right doesn't feel genuine
so I think that's a very beautiful point
that you made my man and um if you guys
will permit I have a few super chats and
a few chats here Insha'Allah
trouble David Salman says if I saw the
Warner giving Dao I'd stay behind the
whole day as a bodyguard we must support
our brothers while they give dawah Allah
Ami but I don't think he needs it I
think you might need it inshallah
[Laughter]
obriak says love all y'all brothers uh
y'all I'll do a great job and I'm happy
to support as a Puerto Rican raver like
Angel I could say that both y'all
channels have helped my emans
foreign
our brother says have no fear of the
Warner is here
bro I'm still on the fact that like when
when the woman said that he's gonna get
his second wife he didn't say he's gonna
get a second wife because he's gonna
order a second one
hey you're supposed to move away from
them
yo yo don't take your Islamic advice
from the Lord
is
it's fun being on a live stream with you
guys bro alhamdulillah like I'm enjoying
this a life
for like almost a month together like
it's dope man I feel like I feel like
it's a bunch of a bunch of Brothers just
getting together and just having a chat
you know yeah
it's not the same though we got to do it
again yeah we do we have to we have to
do it again why not why not
we'll do in person next time Michelle
I'll link up and we'll do it in person
yeah sure that'll be proper inshallah
all right so we'll take some comments
here inshallah
Allah is his bodyguard 100 I think
that's something people need to realize
more bro what what is he talking about
that right because I'm not I'm not gonna
lie
obviously there's there's times where
you know obviously I'm there completely
by myself right but we'll Lockheed bro I
do not feel like I am by myself if I had
the ability to have the veils lifted
above my eyes and I could see what's in
the spiritual world I swear I feel like
there's millions of angels literally
standing next to me bro and I feel so
powerful I literally feel like Goku
going Super Saiyan bro that's how I feel
bro I feel like a one-man Army I don't
need no one else bro as long as I have
Allah is my protector and I truly
believe that Allah will protect me and
it just gives me this power and well it
just it's amazing I could feel it like
it's an electric all throughout my body
and I feel like bro it's all good bro
like no matter what happens I trust in
Allah and I trust in Allah's uh ability
to protect me you know so it is uh
because it's crazy man if you guys see
the other side of the camera the way
that these individuals look at me right
as a proud strong Muslim right and also
a young Muslim I just turned 30. I'm not
like an old man out here you know
sharing the message of a young man out
here Sharing The Message of Islam you
know so
when people see that they do not like it
they look at me with so much hatred and
literally like there's a verse of the
Quran that talks about the way they look
at you they're cutting you to pieces
with their eyes and I can feel it I
could feel it there's even certain times
when you know when I'm out there and I
have the Quran playing there's people
that walk by and they put their fingers
in their ears right and the same thing
happened at the time Prophet Muhammad
right so for me it's very very
interesting doing this but for me this
is an extremely Iman building experience
like it truly is Iman building
experience like I just feel like my Iman
is just like it's just growing at a at a
insane level just by having these types
of experiences like I'm truly only
relying on Allah for protection and I
just see how Allah protects me right
that suddenly there's Muslims you know
even though I'm by myself suddenly
there'll be Muslims coming to the
boardwalk from all different parts of
the world you know and they're there for
support you know like uh
um so it's truly amazing man Allah but
Allah is the greatest Allah is the
greatest protector Allah is the greatest
provider and Allah is the most merciful
man I'm just so grateful you know to be
a Muslim because honestly if I wasn't a
Muslim I don't know how I would be as a
human being I don't know how I would be
as a person like it's completely taken
over my identity as a human being and I
absolutely love it I absolutely love it
alhamdulillah
bro so with that being said
do you feel like when you first started
on the Tao scene and you got out to the
streets and you started giving a Dao do
you feel like things have been changing
like in your your delivery and the way
that you process the stress and just the
interactions with these people that
you're talking to
well yeah
well think about me I'm always trying to
get better I'm always trying to get
better like obviously you guys went on a
trip with me to to Omaha I have a
backpack full of books right full of
books I'm always trying to read I'm
always trying to understand I'm always
trying to get better as an individual
this is kind of how I am I am a little
bit when I get into something I really
really get into it you know so I want to
be the best at whatever it is that I'm
trying to achieve and alhamdulillah I'm
in the process of trying to make history
I want to be in the Islamic history
books as one of the greatest Muslims and
the greatest dawah man to ever step foot
in American soil so that is the goal
inshallah and I will try to achieve it
until my last breath inshallah
and all of us as well I mean
I mean I think that's beautiful bro we
actually you know fight or not we're in
an Uber today
and the driver he was a Hindu and I was
talking to the driver and I was asking
about his belief
and he was telling me he's like oh I'm
Hindu and I'm Christian
and I was like Rory how does this work
he's like oh well he he's been doing
this whole Hinduism thing since he was a
kid and he would go to the church with
his friends and then he just kind of
stayed with that and he believes in it
and I'm like but that that kind of it
doesn't make sense you're kind of like
trying to dip your feet in every single
place so that's I started talking about
Islam and he understood really Islam was
he yeah she vibed with it and then when
I asked him if he read the uh the
scriptures like the ancient beta
scriptures of Hinduism and he said no
and I was like bro you should really
look into it and he's like oh well I
don't really like getting too deep I'm
like but you should look for the answers
you know it's it's a genuine question
that we have like why are we here what's
the purpose where are we going after
this and when you look into the ancient
bit of Scriptures it says that there's
only one God
and then Jesus
peace be upon he also says there's only
one God so I tried telling him I tried
bringing it together I'm like look in
the beginning in Hinduism
they were saying there's only one God in
Christianity what it was supposed to be
they were saying it's only one God so
don't you think that like what you're
doing is kind of going against the main
message but he stayed quiet he didn't
say anything else he didn't respond to
anything else and it's like at that
point it just it clicked in my head it's
like you know what
the only way you get better at dawa is
to continuously do dawa continuously be
trying to give Dao so this is why I
asked with you if like it has been
evolving for you in the way that you
give double I know that you read the
books but you feel like when you've been
talking to people and having these
conversations that it's just allowed you
to just better fine-tune everything to
where you can deliver the messages much
more efficiently
absolutely absolutely 100
um you know this is It's All About trial
and error and for me I completely
learned from all my mistakes you know
obviously I I believe that there's every
time I I kind of uh look back at a
certain situation I was like you know
what I could have said this I could have
said this better okay now I know what to
do better you know so every single
moment that I have a different
conversation with another individual 100
like you know I I realized hey I could
word this a little bit my way of giving
dawa is I want to simplify as much as
possible for people to understand
complex topics right and make them easy
to understand that is my whole goal
right is to make it easy I want to be
like a religion for dummies type of you
know like uh you know instruction manual
so I could share the message with as
many people as possible because
unfortunately obviously in America uh
you know probably around most of the
world most people are not smart bro
that's the reality people are not smart
so you can't talk to them like they are
smart you have to literally talk to them
I'm sorry if this might be offensive I
talk to most people like I'm talking to
a child you know what I mean like I'm
gonna explain it to them the way I
explain to a child because obviously
there's a saying that if you cannot
explain a concept to a child that means
you do not
understand the concept right so I
believe that's important to talk to
people in a way where you simplify
things in the most simplest form so that
way it digests for a larger demographic
of people right and when you are
mentioning
um you know when you were mentioning you
know the the man you know the Hindu guy
right and how you know he's a Hindu and
a Christian it made me uh immediately
think about some verses of Surah Yasin
do you mind if I recite and share for
you guys please go ahead bro okay
yeah see foreign
[Music]
it says in the name of Allah the most
compassionate the most merciful right
yeah seen by the Quran rich in wisdom
you o Prophet are truly one of the
messengers upon the Street Path this is
a revelation from the almighty most
merciful so you may warn a people whose
forefathers were not warned and are so
heedless he immediately made me think
about that how obviously most likely
that individuals that you spoke to he's
just following the customs of his
forefathers right and his forefathers
most likely were not warned of the truth
and now you are here to warn them of the
truth when their forefathers have not
been warned of the truth may Allah bless
you my brother on hell and may Allah
bless all you guys you know because all
of us we're all on the same path of
trying to spread Islam in the most
effective manner possible you know and
uh yeah so immediately this made me
think about this verse
that's a beautiful voice
Ricky
hierarchy for the uh super sticker and
um alhamdulillah
um you know yesterday a brother invited
me to give dawa today
um
and uh I didn't know if I was gonna be
able to make it oh look look at Robin
man no you just want to give him the
kiss on his forehead bro give him a big
hug man
I love this guy he's never bless you bro
bear hug I walked in with a bear hug you
know I mean
I love you guys may Allah bless you all
immensely hello man I mean I don't know
what I did but um
the pink in the background making
everyone feel lovely
yeah
[Music]
there you go
all right
um
today I don't know if I was gonna be
able to make it I still don't know if I
if I will but uh inshallah I'm gonna
push myself as much as possible to go
out
um which by the way if you know anyone
who needs dawa send them out to Niagara
Falls the Canadian side the nice look
inside shallah will be there for uh
maybe a few hours before I've thought
um but uh yeah alhamdulillah has been
you know very very encouraging and um it
reminds me you know like it just
recently my heart has been kept like
being pushed back to this place where I
remember the prophet saws and I remember
who he was and how he lived and how he
acted and how much the people loved him
for how genuine and kind and sincere he
was and it just it makes me want to be
that person I felt like when I was 18 17
I first step to the slam I really
started to become that I feel like maybe
over time some people including myself
when they give Dabo they end up becoming
a little bit bitter you know what I mean
they become a little bit sour a little
bit bitter but towards the people just
because of the things that they have to
put up with the process had them never
became that person he never became
bitter he never became this sour into uh
individual he was always so loving and
sincere and compassionate even even you
know people who rejected the truth for
years and years and years he never
betrayed them he never insulted everyone
and guess them just he was just such a
genuine guy like I look at myself I'm
like yo man you know uh pity I feel pity
for myself because it's it's it's it's
so sad that this is the level of you
know of of of dawood I feel like I've
gotten to I need to go back to the the
Sunday of the process I need to go back
to how the prophet sallam gave dawah and
I think this has been such a beautiful
wake-up call for that you know it's
interesting that you brought that up you
know because one of the reasons why I
first started dawa is mainly because of
like I'm not gonna lie like let's say
for instance if you were to watch My
First videos like I came out there when
I went out on the streets well I came
for vengeance like because so many
people were talking so bad about Islam
you know what I mean and for me I felt
like I needed to represent Islam in a
very like Warrior fierce type weight you
know what I mean but once I realized the
more and people more and more people I
talk to I realized the amount of people
who truly like know Islam then hate
Islam is extremely small extremely small
the reality is most people are
completely ignorant about Islam and as
soon as I recognize that I calm down I
completely calm down all this built up
animosity that I had like for instance
here I'll show you guys something
um that they do at the so at the Santa
Monica Pier right there's ever since I
started getting towel out there now they
have these individuals right who
basically
um
spread misinformation about Islam right
and one of so they basically hand out
anti-islam brochures to people right and
uh it's like a church that does that
right
um as soon as the church that hands out
anti-islam information to people to push
them away from Islam right and you know
it's just crazy like what's happening
because obviously the the movement is
getting out there like people are
hearing what's going on people are now
visiting from all different parts of the
world just to come have a discussion and
to learn about Islam but now the amount
of Christian presence on that Pier has
intensified probably times 10. you know
I mean like let's say before there was
one or two preachers on the pier now
there's like eight to ten and there's
also people handing out anti-islam
things so I'm not gonna lie like when
you go out and you do this street dollar
it's not what you guys think it is this
is war with shaytan if you're not
prepared to go to war with the devil
then you're not prepared for this like
this is just stay at home you know like
if you're not ready if you're not ready
to go to war with shaitaan then you know
you don't know what you're getting into
and dawah is deeper than what you think
it is you are basically Breaking All the
knots and breaking all the all the uh
you know all the lies right and bringing
people towards the truth you're
literally taking people out of darkness
and bringing them into the light right
and you're going to war against evil and
we're living in a time where the amount
of evil right the amount of power evil
has right is extremely high because
obviously I I personally believe that we
are living in the beginning of the end
times and these are the times right
where the shaytan and the army of the
shaitaan is gonna have their highest
level of power obviously in the
beginning of time shaytan was extremely
inferior because most people were on the
truth right now we're living in a
different time where most people are not
on the truth they have been lied to and
the truth has been hid away from the
people and now the lies are front screen
for everybody to see
I wanted to say it on me bro after
hearing that I know you're too fired up
to not give down tonight yeah yeah
bro I was gonna say man this is
this makes me just understand that that
was such a
a top thing for us as Muslims to do
whereas I think about it it's like you
said it's it's a very difficult thing
you're going to war with shaytan but not
only this you also have to deal with the
other person's ego and you also have to
deal with your own ego
because there's how many people give
dawah and then they end up altering the
message at some point and instead of
calling to Islam like you said in the
beginning they call to themselves
you know or like let's say you're giving
dawah let's say you have your ego in
check and you you're over here facing
like all this the share theme like bro
how you win the Pew and you had this one
guy who came at you and uh did he spit
on you or did you spit on him which one
was it
oh no he he took a bottle of soda and he
threw it at me okay so you had people
like this that are like the shaked on
like coming out from the extremities the
outside
but then now you have this one person
let's say you you got the shaytan taking
care of you got your own ego taken care
of now you have this person's ego that
you have to basically disarm in order
for the message to go through
and that's difficult bro that's very
very difficult it takes a lot of
patience and a lot of um emotional
intelligence yes
[Laughter]
honestly most of all it takes extreme
amounts of Courage that that's what it
takes courage bravery you know wisdom
you you know and just the pure genuine
intentions you must have genuine
intentions when they're going out there
because there's something about it like
when you're not genuine your words just
won't penetrate into the hearts of the
people when you are genuine you mean
what you say you say what you mean like
there's a way there's a certain art
about that that just it penetrates the
hearts of the individuals and they can
just feel what you're saying and they
feel that you truly care about them they
feel that you truly love them and you
want what's best for them and then at
the end of the day you have to also
remember that dawah like we're not the
Christians we're not here to force
anyone into believing you know what I
mean like our job is very simple we are
just there to portray the message as
best fit as we can right and that's it
you do the best within your means and
Allah will do the rest it's actually
quite easy but you must understand that
there is a spiritual warfare going on
like for instance let's say if I tell
somebody that's never went to do dawa
with me before that hey uh tomorrow I
need someone at like three o'clock make
sure you're ready right the night before
the shaytan is gonna go to war with them
in a way that they've never faced before
and they they go through certain
challenges the night before they go out
with me just to hinder them from even
going out with me you know how many
times I wasn't able to go out because I
didn't have uh because I need at least
one person with me when I go out because
the thing is I take so much stuff right
that I can't carry it all by myself so I
need at least one person to help me
carry some of the stuff you know
um so usually when I do invite a certain
individual a person that hasn't came out
with me before that night they go to
such a war with the shaytan right that
they've never like felt this type of
battle before right and it's mainly
because they're about to go and do the
dawa now I realize before people come
out with me to dudawa I warned them like
hey all right okay you want to come out
with me okay cool you're about to be
tested tonight be ready pass your test
I'll see you tomorrow you know what I
mean I already know what's gonna happen
because the shaytan is not that smart he
does the same things over and over and
over again it's just humans that
unfortunately are not that smart right
as well and we fall for the same tricks
over and over and over again
alhamdulillah now I do have a brother
that's with me his name is rayon and he
has that uh Warrior type mentality as
well he knows that the shaitaan is this
is a trick a track from the shaytan
alhamdulillah he's accustomed to Fat
fighting these wars with the shaitaan so
alhamdulillah he's been successful we've
been able to be able to go out with me
you know uh for a long time now
alhamdulillah and because of that I
actually took him with me to umrah as a
gift you know because he's been helping
me out so much and he's only 18 19 years
old bro young man but tons of Courage
bro tons of courage
and I love bless him and I love this
absolutely absolutely shout out to my
boy rayon shout out to my boyfriend
yeah
he'll be big in the devil scene if he's
starting at the stage
we do have a few uh more Super chats
um on Hills is for you
again
Translate
bro my train is my my Spanish is rough
bro I'm gonna tell you that
uh it's saying be careful Brothers when
the three Muslims and the wanna get
together
foreign
and um
I can't I can't understand the last part
no King I I'm not sure what no king is
though
but it's uh oh it's uh I think knockout
like take out the the lives or something
like this I'm not hey all I know is that
the brother had the best attention to
you and I love everybody when we all get
together y'all better watch out
inshallah we're forced to be reckoned
with man alhamdulillah the four Muslims
the four Muslims
the five Muslims
and uh someone actually said looking
forward to a three Muslims and the
Warner and social shooter you already
got one bro what you mean yeah we
technically kind of already got one um
yeah
the Warner didn't make an appearance
of the day bro but what I did want to
say
is that something that I learned before
Islam is that when you're about to make
a breakthrough
that's when you're tested the most
that's when the devil attacks you the
most and there was this whole saying
before it's like for every level there's
a new Devil but it's really like right
when you're about to do something that's
really gonna make a breakthrough whether
it's in your life or in someone else's
life that's when you're attacked by
shaytan the most and it's crazy that you
said that because it just it literally
affirms this that as you are telling
someone oh look I need you for dollar
tomorrow at X time that's when the
shaytan starts attacking them in certain
ways I think it's crazy bro yeah it's
actually talking and piggyback on the
piggybacking on that
um it's actually really very it's very
interesting
for a number of years now alhamdulillah
even before I started doing the straight
dawa I've been going to war with shaitan
for a minute for a number of years so I
will I could kind of say I'm a veteran
in shaytan Warfare you know what I'm
saying so uh um so I realized the days
that is toughest for me to go out and
give dawa is the days I must go out
because the amount of obstacles that are
coming in my way in order to stop me
that means there's something that's
supposed to happen that day that the
shaitaan does not want to happen and
obviously if he doesn't want it to
happen if the shaytan doesn't want it to
happen I definitely want it to happen
you understand because I'm not here to
please him I'm here to please Allah the
creator of all things right so I notice
when there's days where it's like you
know I call my my guy rayon I was like
hey is it shaytan attacking you you say
yeah it's attacking your teeth okay we
have to go out now there's something
about to happen today and next you know
most of the time those are the days that
the shahadas end up happening because
you have to understand things happen in
the spiritual world before they happen
in our world right so let's say if a
person was going to accept Islam that
day it's already coming down right in
the spiritual world right and the
xiaotein are informed of it so now they
do whatever they can to stop that from
happening right but then they start
whispering in my ears they start
whispering in my other brother's ears
right try to deter us from coming then
they'll whisper into like different
family members or this or that to deter
to stop me any way possible Right
and then that's why I noticed that these
are days I need to go out the most and
usually those are the days where people
come up and they end up taking this you
already know what someone takes their
shahada right and you know let's say
they're they're 50 years old and they
take their shahada for 50 years the
shaitaan and the Shay Alton the army of
the have been working on that individual
in order to misguide them and suddenly
one day they come across the giant
Muslim and now subhanallah they are
granted guidance through the mercy of
Allah and they end up accepting Islam
all the work of the shaitaan the past 50
years that the shaytan has been
misguiding him has all been wiped away
what do you think that's gonna do you
think that's going to make the shaytan
happy or you think it's going to make
them angry
so now all
things you know what I mean and
obviously for me I'm very I like to be
aware of things as much as possible like
I pay attention to everything you know
so obviously just from the small amount
of time that I have uh I've been doing
the spiritual warfare with the shaitaan
I've been noticing these certain things
that do happen and it's usually in the
days that it's hardest for me to go out
something really really special is going
to happen that day and there's a certain
person that's going to receive the Quran
and receive the message that the
shaitaan did not want to hear the truth
that he was probably having you know
misguiding him and wanting to keep keep
him on his guidance
and you know it's it's beautiful that
you mentioned all this because we we got
a very beautiful Super Chat
um that I think really really shows the
power of dawa and the power of Islam Jay
grow for show said Thank You Warner and
the three Muslims that became a Muslim
on April 2nd so very recently
alhamdulillah one of the few things that
I've been sure of in my life so a big
thanks Brothers
our brother uh the honor is ours
hamdullah and uh we're very very happy
to have you as our brother in Islam
Allah increase you and bless you must
say Allah I mean and
um yeah bro Warner man you're gonna be
more fired up to go and uh you know piss
the shaytan off yeah I'm actually after
after this that's what I'm gonna do I'm
literally I'm going out to go dawa so if
anybody's in the LA area just feel free
to pull up inshallah and uh yeah you
know I I I'm I'm looking forward to it
you know what I mean haters especially
hey you already know I got something for
him you know what I'm saying
a long lavatic all right I think uh
we're getting close to ending the stream
off here inshallah so we'll save final
remarks final comments Final Super chats
make sure you send them now mashallah
before we end off but uh so it looks
like after the stream I'm gonna go give
dawa after the shame uh the one is gonna
go give dawa which means fat and Angel
after the stream inshallah you guys
should get out and go give dawa as well
goes
yeah so what's funny is without airing
exactly where we are I got to New York
with Angel and our brother SQ he sent me
a message saying hey man I'm near XYZ
location where we live in Canada right
near Toronto and he's like can you guys
pull up and I'm like bro I'm literally
in your ends and you're in my ends so
like because he's known for you know
that one Time Square that are we in
Times Square zamzam Boys in Times Square
that's where we're very close but he's
in the orange so unfortunately we can't
this time and he had a big event dude
they're all we in Times Square Mel look
bless the brother man this is like such
a massive event and I believe it was so
important what it is that he did because
most people they like to pay attention
and like the argumentations against
Islam so on and so forth right obviously
in the Quran it says in chapter 14 right
I believe uh let me see the verse uh
that talks about Surah Ibrahim right uh
the people who sort of says uh uh so
it's Chapter 14 verse 4 right so it's uh
they are the ones who favor the life of
this world over the Hereafter and they
hinder others from accepting the way of
Allah striving it striving to make it
appear crooked right it is they who have
gone far astray obviously the Quran
warns us of the tactics of the
disbelievers right and how they try to
portray Islam in a crooked way to keep
people away from the truth so one of the
things that I believe is absolutely
amazing is we need to show them the
spiritual side of Islam mainly the the
need to hear the actual words of the
Quran and obviously for me that's why
when I give dawah I make sure to
implement as many verses of the Quran as
I can because most people have never
heard the Quran before and there's a
certain power of the Quran that people
have to recognize and realize right that
the Quran has so much power in it right
so if we believe that this is truly a
book from God then we must relay the
information the way that the prophets
and the sahabas did and they would
recite the Quran to the people and
immediately their hearts will be turned
right from from misguidance to guidance
right so that's why I try to implement
that as well and what obviously our
brother uh SQ whale life SQ right uh may
Allah blessed brother
you know he's putting uh the the way
that the Muslims pray on the world stage
you know so for me like I think that's
incredibly like that's so smart right
and that's gonna bring a certain
different depiction of Islam because
most people they don't even know the way
we pray they never heard the Quran they
just hear the jibber jabber from the
disbelievers you know from the enemies
of Islam well you know it's amazing that
you mentioned that because of this
message from the sister Patricia she
says I've been considering but I want I
want to do with my son and the more I
talk about Islam to my mom she pushes
away and I get videos on why Islam is
false it's a headache literally it's
found a lot so we have our our sister
who wants to step Islam
I believe she mentioned with her son as
well and she has people who are trying
to push her away from Islam just by
sending her all these videos
um first and foremost in regards to the
videos
um I'm sure you know this there's
nothing to worry about a lot of them are
just what brother uh the Warner had
mentioned that they misconstrue Islam
they lie about the verses they're going
based off of an English translation to
begin with so using the discrepancies
they try and twist the words
um and obviously you know we don't let
them get away with it there have been
many videos debunking these
alhamdulillah
um but I would just say just accept
Islam you don't have to tell your mom
you don't have to tell anyone except
Islam even you and your son except Islam
um you know you have contact with the
Muslims here you inshallah you can visit
that messages well we are here for you
anything you need insha Allah just just
accept the truth of Islam don't worry
about anybody else and if you have
anything more specific that you need to
share with us please do inshallah so we
can help to the best of our ability I
would like to
like this shirt as well if you guys
don't mind
so what I would like to say with the
sister that the closer and closer you
get to the truth the more the shaytan is
going to attack you in ways that you've
never been attacked so if you're seeing
this right if you're recognizing this
then know that you're getting closer and
closer to the truth and now it's up to
you to overcome this obstacle if you
truly want peace and you truly want
Paradise if you want Paradise you have
to work for it nobody said it's going to
be easy so these are the obstacles that
are in your way you must overcome these
obstacles if you want what all of us
desire which is Paradise
absolutely absolutely there's a very
beautiful verse
talks about this Allah says do you think
that we would Grant you Jannah basically
without testing you
and um that that is what life is you
know it's it's tests and tests and tests
so God can differentiate those who are
truthful and True Believers from those
who are not so may Allah make us True
Believers and allow us to pass our tests
Allah I mean and sister we are here for
you inshallah if you need it I think you
seem like you're basically a muslim with
the way you you left that comment
um and what you said you seem like
you're basically a Muslim you just have
to accept it and actually take your
shahada to officially become a Muslim so
uh we're here for you Insha'Allah
um we have a few more Super chats
uh Mr flippy says everything became
Muslim because of you guys and others on
YouTube could you ask the Warner where I
could buy the prayer mats he gives out
those from Medina boys they're pretty
much like these guys know how hard it is
for me to get prayer mats like these
guys first have have seen how difficult
it is I literally travel across the
entire world in order to get those
prayer mats and I spend tons of money on
overweight baggage on extra baggage and
all that stuff in order to get that to
people I'm sorry but I am not going to
ship out any of those paramounts to
anyone they're exclusively for the
people who come and visit me so the only
way for you to get those prayer mats is
for you to come and visit me in La if
not then you would have to go out to the
holy city of Mecca yourself and go ahead
and get it yourself inshallah
Knows Best
yes
um our brother or reacts he was the one
who left the uh the comment in Spanish
she said I was saying don't kill the
Liars when y'all link up with the big
inshallah ah so I I uh translated it
correctly then
and then last one here Raymond says
respect for all the Warren and nice to
see with the three Muslims may Allah
strengthen you guys uh you guys is that
what I love to love to see
on with you guys as well inshallah
inshallah bless the brother uh he's
doing amazing work man they'll preserve
him and they'll continue to make him as
a source of guidance for many
individuals I mean I mean I mean
all right and uh with that being said I
think we're good to go ahead and wrap up
the stream Insha'Allah
I feel like we should make that
for us and for the people this has been
a very touching stream
may Allah forgive us for our
shortcomings anything that we have said
that was incorrect may Allah correct us
and allow us to correct ourselves
may Allah except from us our good deeds
and may Allah allow us to be leaders for
the righteous may Allah allow us to give
dawah in the best way and that is the
way of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam who was sincere and compassion
is thou may Allah make us sincere and
compassionate and again accept it from
us Allah I mean may Allah protect us
from the punishment of this life the
Hereafter and of the punishment of the
fire may Allah open all the gates of
Jannah for us and allow us to reach the
highest levels of Jannah and all unite
there Allah I mean
before we end
up what was that uh well awesome that
one yeah
oh man I don't know if that one's a I
don't know if I I haven't read that one
in a while I want to make it uh
um
foreign
what did you say
yeah I remember it now now that he said
it you know but yeah you guys go ahead I
haven't read that one in a long time so
I want to mess up you know
so the reason before I translate the
reason I asked for this Surah in
particular is because the sahaba used to
recite this to each other before they
part ways and it's because it's so short
it's so compact but it's so powerful
that Imam Allah he said that if Allah
only revealed this Surah it would have
been enough because it talks about all
the main kind of aspects of Islam so
Allah he swears by time he says he
swears by time and Asura is time that's
running out right so he swears by time
that is running out indeed mankind as a
whole they're in loss right they're lost
except and he gives an exception here
everyone's lost except these people
except those who believe
and do good deeds and exalt each other
to the truth and exalt each other
towards patience
how beautiful is that so if you want to
be from those who are not lost
and those who are the exception to the
the people who are lost then you have to
believe
and do good deeds and believe and call
each other to the truth and believe in
and call each other towards patience as
well
and with that being said
inshallah we'll see you guys on the next
one
if you go with that yeah yeah I mean I
was having so much fun bro
yo I have a I have a great idea uh a few
weeks ago we did this uh this stream but
we had people give like their
assumptions their assumptions over us
and we responded we reacted to those
assumptions and bro mashallah was it was
a great time it was hilarious people
loved it I think we should run that uh
with you and we should definitely do it
yeah we should do like a reacting to
assumptions with the Warner or like some
challenges or something you know there's
a lot of yeah yeah where it's like it
brings that humor aspect to it it like
brings lightness to the the air but at
the same time there's like room for like
wisdom and knowledge to be thrown in at
the same time
I mean we'll see I mean I'm not gonna
answer all the questions
yeah we ain't trying to do the Warner
Expos 2020. okay okay 20 25. you can you
complete the fifth bro
I plead the fifth I plead the fifth
there you go only work for you because
you're the only American here well I
don't think we have that what do you
guys my bad I believe
all right not for real inshallah we're
gonna end it off if the Warner permits
inshallah
may Allah protect us and inshallah we'll
do this again soon hopefully in person
as well
um with that being said